un homme de droite dure séguinisme
n'avait jamais été mon ami effectuons
que je courais pas être votre ami je
déjeune ensemble ils vont me trouviez
sympathique je ne sais pas si je me
trouvais sympathique en tout cas en tout
cas vous le montrions parce que quand on
parlait déjà mais je ne pensais pas que
vous devriez ce leader d'extrême-droite
que vous êtes aujourd'hui on va parler
non mais oui leader d'extrême droite oui
monsieur savez bourillon s'est rappelé
le général de gaulle fascisme donc comme
vous prenez pour le théâtre pour le
général quand et si votre
ne marche pas avec moi en or mais vous
allumez le général de gaulle et vous
pensez d'engranger un acteur un mauvais
acteurs du théâtre anti fasciste et
j'aimerais qu'on veut dire vous
attendiez parlementaire c'est un non pas
du tout je pense que la victoire est
bien lionel jospin vous fait d'être anti
fasciste alors vous traiter tous vos
adversaires de fascistes mais c'est la
leçon de votre maître joseph staline je
vous ai traités leader d'extra nous
c'est la même chose vous êtes un homme
d'extrême mais bien sûr oui on va on va
parler d'eux les attendait eric zemmour
à l'excellent droite allait depuis le
début quand on vous interpelle sur un de
vos livres il faut pas parler de vos
livres vous parler maintenant de ce que
vous dites maintenant ben oui dame
curieux de la part d'un homme pas du
tout sisi pas du tout maintenant je vous
dit hier leader d'extrême droite non
vous n'êtes pas les droits de gestion
leader d'extrême droite il existe
radicalise
dieu ne plaise d'accord les mecs qui
veut renverser la république envers ses
importants donc eric zemmour vous ne
considérez pas comme un leader déclarent
lire et féministe il n'est pas d'extrême
droite il est touchant jamais digéré
d'ordures madame morano a compris que
j'ai répondu à madame morellec on peut
pas vous allez en bouche pardon vous
êtes extrêmement moins cher républicain
social mais je dire je ne me mets pas à
bon d'accord non mais vous êtes
d'extrême gauche pardon êtes d'extrême
gauche c'est comme ça qu'on qualifie met
d'accord si moi je moi je me cachais
dans l'échiquier politique et ben voila
moi je me qualifie comme abolisse
bonapartiste d'accord très bien alors on
va parler maintenant on peut parler à
les y aller on va parler des sujets qui
nous réglait le problème de l'école
exactement ce que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire géographie au lycée
professionnel c'est parti alexis
corbière parce que bout dit eric zemmour
dès la rentrée prochaine nous referons
de l'école l'instrument de
l'assimilation à la française et nous
chasserons des classes de nos enfants le
pédagogisme l'islamo gauchisme et
l'idéologie lgbt vous avez dit sale lors
de votre meeting alors alexis oui donc
bon je pense que la république
souvent ces démos mais c'est d'abord des
actes concrets et ça se matérialise dans
les services publics et le premier
service public c'est l'école l'école
publique laïques et républicaines et
vous cette phrase c'est un triptyque
dans lequel on retrouve tous les montres
à qu'on connaît depuis des années des
mensonges des fantasmes et fanta contre
l'école républicaine de cette vieille
haine contre l'école républicaine et
d'une violence verbale contre le monde
enseignant et l'ensemble de ceux qui
font vivre l'école publique oui monsieur
pendant une époque les gens comme vous
dont vous êtes l'héritier parce que vous
êtes les héritiers d'une histoire hélas
française il considérait que l'école est
entre les mains des francs maçons et
puis à présent considéré que l'école et
entraînement des instituteurs socialiste
entre les mains des communistes et pas
précités les maoïstes les trotskistes
aujourd'hui vous c'est le lobby
homosexuel celle pédagogie et toute une
série de sottises qui chaque fois fait
diversion sur les vrais problèmes de
l'école publique parce qu'il ya des
vrais problèmes à l'école publique
l'otan les politiques qui ont été menées
qui ont supprimé des postes qui font
qu'aujourd'hui en seine saint denis ce
département que vous vomissez même si
vous êtes né mais que vous vomissez vous
savez quoi nos enseignants ils sont pas
remplacés quand ils sont malades les
professeurs aujourd'hui à cause du gel
du point d'indicé notamment des
politiques qui ont été menées par les
gouvernements y gagne aujourd'hui 15 à
20% de moins que ce que gagne un autre
professeur dans un pays qui au nom de l'
ocde est ce que vous savez que les
investis ces dames c'est surtout un
métier féminin qui s'occupe des enfants
dans les écoles publiques elles sont
payées 700 euros est ce que vous savez
que dans les classes françaises
comparativement à d'autres pays d'europe
il ya plus d'élèves que dans les autres
de deux trois quatre cinq élèves et tout
ça au bout d'un moment ça fait baisser
le niveau parce que y compris derrière
une réalité dont on parle de l'école
c'est pas la même école publique selon
koné comme chez vous je veux pas rentrer
dans le détail de votre vie privée vous
vivez dans beaux quartiers parisiens en
tant mieux pour vous grandit les lycées
publics aujourd'hui n'est pas le même
que chez moi au sein de sanyo c'est pour
ça que tout à l'heure je me suis mis en
colère jamais assez que des gens passent
leur temps à détester la seine saint
denis notamment quand les femmes sera
agressée c'est la faute à la
seine-saint-denis quant à des problèmes
à l'école publique c'est la faute aux
professeurs aux lobbys lgbt déjà c'est
quoi le lobby homosexuel mobile gpt
c'est quoi le pédagogisme je peux vous
citer un pédagogistes pourquoi on
comprenne juste tous que la phrase et
vous allez me dire qu'est ce que vous
avez contre cette phrase c'est la
méthode qui consiste à ne plus dictée
comme un arrêt à la règle à l'enfant
mais elle lui fait retrouver elle se
propose avant tout des veillées la
spontanéité de l'enfant pour en
surveiller et dirigé le développement
normal au lieu de l'emprisonner dans
derek tout fait auquel il ne comprend
rien vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça
non d'accord ouais ça comme pédagogie ce
qu'a dit ça sans doute vous savez qui
c'est jules ferry voilà à la connais par
coeur je le fais rien pédagogistes mais
aujourd'hui c'est un jeu construit
l'école monsieur campillo paix
alexis de salaires promises choses pour
vous et la merde et monsieur n'avait
juste alexis sa démission et
l'allocution est comme ça vous lupopo
voulu perdre quand vous parlez de mon
héritage eux moi j'aimerais bien parler
du vôtre vous n'avez pas encore candidat
à l'élection d'un homme siècle en bière
ne faites pas dire non je fais pas
diversion je verrai bon quand je réponds
comme je veux parler de mon héritage
politique indécente à suez moi je vais
répondre de votre d'inscrire faut savoir
d'où vous venez vous êtes un militant
veilleux communiste dans l'hérault vous
avez vous avez le buste de lénine vous
êtes un admirateur de la révolution
communiste soviétique qui a tué des
centaines de millions de gens parlaient
d'eux est venu chez moi
est ce que vous vous rangez le ced je
sais comme celle d'un héritier de
staline vous êtes les admirateurs de
redessiner avait cambriolé un admirateur
de robespierre d'or non il ya aussi des
milliers de personnes c'est faux bah ça
d'accord bah vous discuté de ça avec
mélenchon alors ça c'est au moins une
affaire vous avez un point commun tous
les deux vous adorez l'histoire absolue
donc c'est vrai ça vous devriez pouvoir
absolu t adore vous avez dit beaucoup de
bêtises tout à l'heure oui bon c'est
encore trop parlé dans mes dents
notamment sur l'histoire oui mais vous
êtes admirateurs vous de napoléon
absolument d'accord j'ai pris mes deux
temps le peuple français je veux dire
autant que sur les non non non il a
sauvé la révolution la colle et moi
malaisie 4 les élections des 603 il
demande à ce que il y est notamment une
réglementation sur les prénoms c'est
qu'elles étaient des prénoms qui était
donné par les français démarrent et non
révolutionnaire marat kléber carnot et
c'est parce que napoléon et où justement
voulu écraser la souvenir de la
révolution dynastie la révolution il a
notamment mis en place cette fois vous
vous réclamez qui n'avaient rien à je
suis évidemment ses norias break samia
pas des musulmans voyons pourquoi vous
en réclamer alors pourquoi vous arrivé
là ben voyons rade